so i just bought the dji om4
to use in my professional career and
today we're going to take a look at
first impressions and why you
as any aspiring architect or architect
in the field
should be getting one of these right now
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich welcome back to the channel
like i already mentioned today we're
talking about the dji
om4 it is the latest and greatest gimbal
from dji and it simply
blurs the lines between architect and
content creator
filmmaker
looking at this device from the get-go
and unboxing it it was a very pleasant
experience
for 240 australian dollars you really
can't go wrong
now i used to do a lot of video making a
lot of content creation
a couple years ago and i had all the
works the big dslr cameras the heavy
gimbals
the backpacks that weighed more than
your travel on luggage
it really became way too much this
little guy
basically weighs nothing in comparison
to that especially when you take off the
tripod at the bottom it becomes even
smaller
a bit of a comfier scene change eh
alright so let's talk about
my first impressions of unboxing the dji
om4
so one of the best things about the dji
om4 is the simple fact it is so light
and so compact
like i already mentioned i'm used to
those big heavy gimbals
that take two arms and end up making
your arms hurt like hell
after a day's worth of work so the
simple fact that it's so light so
compact so easy to use
is a definite win straight out of the
box what was a bit of a concern was it
seemed very fragile
at the start when i had to try and open
it up and click it open
like you see in the ads even the little
grandma can do it
after a few tries and after i actually
understood how the mechanism works
it actually isn't fragile whatsoever
it's quite robust
and it is very sturdy so if you have any
concerns as long as you pull straight up
and you don't twist around
it will be absolutely fine so another
thing i love about the dji om4
is the magnetic grip it has truly
changed it from the om3
and made it a better upgraded device the
magnetic grip comes off so quickly and
so easily
i personally use the grip clamp around
the phone because i don't like
sticking anything to the back of my
phone and using that magnetic clamp
i'd much rather use the simple pull-on
pull-off grip
and then i can use it whenever i want
and store it whenever i don't need it
all you have to remember is to align the
two white dots
when you're connecting the magnets
together and it will be absolutely
perfect
the app does actually tell you when you
haven't aligned the two dots
and when you have to realign it so if
you ever aren't 100
sure you will get told and it makes it
very user-friendly
talking about the technology of the
device and the integration with the
mobile app
some of the auto focusing features are
actually really good
the simple fact that you can click the
trigger just once and it will
automatically grab onto somebody's face
and automatically track that person
without you having to do
anything technical without you having to
draw that person's face on your screen
or literally anything at all makes it a
great
upgrade and a great feature i think one
of the downsides to this however
is it does pivot and change very quickly
especially if that person's moving very
fast
or if any subject in that shot is moving
very fast so it does make it a little
bit unstable
it can also sometimes grab the
completely wrong thing
for example i was trying to capture an
individual today and instead of
capturing them
it captured the printer i i can't
explain that one at all
but it just did so sometimes it won't
capture
what you're trying to connect to and it
will just
malfunction like technology does every
now and again as an architect obviously
i always criticized the design of
something and it wouldn't be
my way if i didn't criticize at least
one error
that i personally see in this device the
button placement is
actually really really good my only
concern
is the zoom button feature it is just
slightly too high to be able to grab
properly with your thumb
so i think it would have been nice if it
was located a little bit lower
and also the very simple fact that the
usbc port is completely exposed to the
elements
talking about negative features as well
the tripod that it comes with
is well one great that it comes with a
free tripod but two is a little bit
cheap and nasty the whole gimbal itself
is built quite well and quite solid
however
the tripod itself is very very cheap
plastic
so now we need to talk about the actual
performance of the gimbal and is
it any good well i tested it out today
and i've tested it out in practice
and it does everything that your proper
big dslr gimbal can do
just as well sometimes a little bit
worse but we'll get to that in a minute
so overall it gets very very smooth
shots it's very easy to control
and it works very similar to the big
gimbals the three axis gimbals that
you'd be used to on a dslr if you've
ever used a big dslr gimbal it is a very
simple
transition to a mobile gimbal if you
haven't it is a bit of a learning curve
before you understand
how the mechanism and the gimbals and
axis work themselves from a negative
point of view though
it does struggle to get the front direct
shots so if you're coming very low to
the bottom of the table and going closer
to a product for example
it does struggle to really tilt the
phone 90 degrees
against that gimbal itself so the only
workaround i've found so far is to tip
the whole gimbal upside down
to be able to use it properly this isn't
the worst thing in the world but i guess
there's definitely some more
improvements that they can work on in
the future
now i just want to quickly point out
this jumper is super warm and super
comfortable
not sponsored not paid for but there is
a link down below if you want to check
it out because it just genuinely is a
very very comfortable jumper
now there is a very simple and very
logical reason why i purchased the om4
over the om3
especially considering the om3 is half
the price of the im4
and it is a simple fact that the om4 has
a 230 gram weight capacity whereas the
om-3
only has a 200 gram capacity i
personally use
a samsung galaxy s20 ultra which comes
in at 226 grams
so i cannot use the om3 unfortunately it
has to be the om4
however having said this if you do have
a phone that comes
in under that 200 gram category i think
it might even be 210
i'll put a little snippet here because i
can't remember off top my head
then you are more than welcome to grab
the om3 it is a great purchase at an
exceptional price at the moment okay so
why at the start of this video did i say
every single architect needs a gimbal
and especially this one
well to be honest you don't need this
gimbal in particular
but you do need some sort of gimbal
mobile phones are getting
more and more advanced and obviously it
is becoming harder and harder to stand
out on social media
everybody is looking to build their own
brand their own business
their own whatever and it is becoming
very hard to do this in 2020
especially now that we're entering a
whole new 2021
where people haven't been able to travel
for 12 months they're eager to get out
and there's going to be so much mass
content produced in a short period of
time
i think it's critical now more so than
ever that you understand
personal branding and truly build up
your own presence
on your social media platforms and
personally i think there's only one way
to do it and that's through video
content
i think video content is the most
powerful the most interactive
and the most genuine form of social
media content that you can create right
now
not only that but videos are showcased
to a lot more people the algorithm
prefers them
and they just genuinely engage better
with people so to be able to create
good content and good videos you do
unfortunately need some sort of gimbal
to be able to create
that cinematography that everybody is
looking for if you're just walking
around using your phone
scrolling around you know taking videos
one it's gonna be
very very jumpy two it's gonna look
amateur as
and three you're just never gonna get
the shots that you're really truly
looking to get especially if you're
aspiring to create
like some of the best youtubers out
there that are creating some incredible
content
every single day anyway that's all from
me today guys thanks so much for
watching
i hope you enjoyed the video i hope you
got some good quality information out of
it if you did
make sure you smash that like button
down below help this video with
the youtube algorithm and if you want to
see more of my videos smash that
subscribe button down below
because as always i will see you next
monday